hin und her nicht auf Sie recht herzlich
heute in der rossauer-kaserne begrüßen
wir starten mit der Pressekonferenz zur
Digitalisierung der Behörden WG im
Bundesheer an meiner Seite darf ich
begrüßen die Verteidigungsministerin
Claudia Tanner und den Staatssekretär
für Digitalisierung Herrn Florian tursky
Frau Minister ich ersuche um Ihre
Ausführungen
der sehr geehrte Damen und Herren es ist
ein Tag der Freude heute wenn ich an der
Seite des Herrn Staatssekretärs für die
Digitalisierung stehen darf wir wissen
das in den letzten Jahren der Bedarf an
der digitalen Transformation immer mehr
zugenommen hat
digitale Technologien sind etwas das uns
hilft dass uns hilft zum Beispiel
Geschäftsmodelle Arbeitsweisen
effizienter zu gestalten und damit auch
unseren alltäglichen den Alltag auch zu
verbessern für uns als österreichisches
Bundesheer ist dieser Schritt in
Richtung Digitalisierung ein unglaublich
wichtiger er bedeutet für uns ein
Ankommen im digitalen Zeitalter und
daher dürfen mein geschätzter Kollege
Herr Staatssekretär Florian dursky und
ich Ihnen heute unsere neue
Online-Plattform Bundeswehr online
präsentieren dem ist sehr viel an Arbeit
vorangegangen federführend in unserer
Direktion Sex der generalmayr ist ja
auch da unsere neue Plattform die
ermöglicht ist das bisher langwierige
und komplexe
Verwaltungsverfahren vereinfacht werden
für alle die noch keinen Wert ins
durchlaufen haben oder wo es schon ein
bisschen länger her ist darf ich ganz
kurz erklären warum es hier geht und
worüber wir heute sprechen ich nehme ein
Beispiel her nach der Einberufung zum
Wehrdienst da was bis heute so dass
unsere Stellungspflichtigen bestimmte
Verfahren durchlaufen mussten um
Formulare für beispielsweise die
wohnkostenbeihilfe Familien Unterhalt
oder auch Bekanntgabe der Bankdaten
auszufüllen die sind dann an die
zuständigen Stellen weitergeleitet
worden das hat Kassen Download von
Formularen ausdrucken Handy ausfüllen
und dann Versand eben per Post und wer
wiederholt von der unbedingt notwendigen
Modernisierung
bundesheerie spricht das tun wir dann
müssen wir dort beginnen wo es
vielleicht auf den ersten Blick nicht
das Notwendigste ist nämlich bei den
Verwaltungsverfahren
wir sprechen über Personalmangel auf
allen Ebenen das tun nicht nur wir das
zieht sich durch den öffentlichen Dienst
in Wahrheit auch durch jedes Unternehmen
daher müssen wir ein attraktiver
Arbeitgeber auch sein wir müssen
moderner werden wir müssen digitaler
werden um dann am Ende des Tages auch am
Arbeitsmarkt wettbewerbsfähig zu sein
und ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir das
mit dieser neuen Plattform mit
Bundeswehr online geschafft haben mit
den ersten digitalen Behörden wegen
können nun bereits etwa 90.000
Bürgerinnen und Bürger pro Jahr dieses
neue Service nutzen dazu zählen nicht
nur Stellungspflichtige sondern auch
präsenzdienstleistungen Miliz Angehörige
und regelungsdienst leistete der Zugang
der findet durch ein gesichertes ist
unabdingbar notwendigen gesichertes
Identifikationsverfahren statt wie etwa
die ID Austria Handy-Signatur oder eine
persönliche Erkennung dort können dann
Formulare wie familienpartner Unterhalt
Wohnkosten Beihilfe Krankenversicherung
von Angehörigen und so weiter angegeben
werden das ermöglicht unseren Usern auch
mit den zuständigen Sachbearbeitern
Referenten Kontakt in Form eines Chats
aufzunehmen das sind insgesamt zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt dann über 100
relevante Verfahren die wir
digitalisieren und wir wollen nach in
den nächsten Jahren diese Plattform
erweitern mit Ende des Jahres soll sie
dann nicht nur den
Grundwert denen sondern auch den
Zivildienst leistenden zur Verfügung
stehen ich habe schon einmal
angesprochen ab heute ab heute ist diese
neue Serviceplattform verfügbar und
können damit auch die genannten
Behördenverfahren genutzt werden sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Digitalisierung
das bringt Vorteile eine moderne eine
digitale aber auch kosteneffizientere
Arbeitsweise für unsere Bediensteten
Prozesse die automatisierter optimierter
werden und auch für unsere
jugendeinstellungspflichtigen ist der
digitale Zugang ein wesentlich einfacher
und gerade als Verteidigungsministerium
mit unseren Verwaltungsstrukturen bildet
diese besondere Schnittstelle zur
zivilen Welt tatsächlich etwas sehr
Wichtiges dürfen nicht vergessen es sind
rund 40.000 Stellungspflichtige pro Jahr
die wir damit sozusagen auch ins moderne
Zeitalter führen mit diesem Projekt
nicht nur die Stellungspflichtigen
sondern generell das österreichische in
Richtung moderner Zukunft vielen Dank
ich ersuche nun den Staatssekretär für
Digitalisierung Herrn florentowski um
seine Worte vielen Dank Frau
Verteidigungsministerin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren normalerweise
wenn wir uns zusammen zu Wort melden
nachher geht es um andere Bereiche des
alltäglichen Lebens die sich in die
digitale Welt begegnen nicht
insbesondere den Bereich Cyber defence
und damit möchte ich starten ich möchte
dir danken für die gute Kooperation in
dieser auch herausfordernden diesen
herausfordernden Bereich das Leben
verlagert sich immer mehr im Internet
deshalb auch geminilität aber natürlich
auch Angriffe von außen und darf mich
beim öffentlichen Bundesheer und auch
bei dir im besonderen für die wirklich
grandiose Zusammenarbeit bedanken heute
sprechen wir aber über einen Bereich der
mich sehr viel betrifft mich die
Modernisierung und Digitalisierung der
österreichischen Verwaltung
wir haben uns mit dem Digital Austria
Act zum Ziel gesetzt bis ins Jahr 2024
alle Amtswege zu digitalisieren und alle
Amtswege bedeutet in Österreich auch
alle Ministerien bedeutet über die
Ministerien hinweg zu arbeiten
ressortübergreifend aber auch für alle
Lebensbereiche und deshalb freue ich
mich sehr dass wir heute präsentieren
dürfen was das für das österreichische
Bundesheer bedeutet nämlich hier auch
alle Amtswege zukünftig mit Bundesheer
online digital anbieten zu können und
ich möchte recht herzlich gratulieren ob
man das Produkt natürlich auch schon
anschauen können es wird dann
präsentiert zu dieser wirklich
innovativen und guten Lösung wie war das
bisher bisher weiß so wie bei den
meisten Amts wegen ein schriftliches
Formular das auszufüllen war das dann
wieder von unseren Abteilungen im
Verteidigungsministerium einzutippen
waren all das gehört der Vergangenheit
an die Frau Bundesministerin hat es
angesprochen insgesamt über 100 Amtswege
die es zu digitalisieren gibt und
gestartet hat man mit denen die am
häufigsten Vorkommen im Familien- und
partnerunterhalt die wohnkostenbeihilfe
die Krankenversicherung von Angehörigen
wir wissen ein ganz wichtiges Thema die
Bekanntgabe von Bankdaten oder die
selbstaufkunft und da um auch ein
Beispiel zu nennen zum Beispiel bei der
Bekanntgabe von Bankdaten waren das im
Jahr über
90.000 Formulare die dort
handschriftlich sozusagen eingegeben und
abgetippt werden mussten diese gehört
nun der Vergangenheit an ganz insgesamt
werden wir also weit über
100.000 handschriftliche Formulare mit
diesem neuen Bundesheer online bereits
jetzt einsparen können
der Zugang dessen die Verb
Bundesministerin hat bereits ausgeführt
ist im Kern die Handy-Signatur oder die
ID Austria weil wir uns ja auch darauf
geeinigt haben als Bundesregierung wir
wollen eine digitale Identität mit der
wir uns im Zukunft im der digitalen Welt
auch vollberechtigt ausweisen können
ganz wichtiges Element von uns wir
wissen normalerweise früher hat man das
mit dem Reisepass oder den
Personalausweis gemacht all das soll
zukünftig auch online sein alle Ausweise
gehören aufs Handy und so also auch die
vollständige die vollständige
Identifikation nun bereits ab dem 29.06
wenn es auch die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer
die Nutzer die zur Stellung geladen
werden oder zur eigentumsprüfungen und
den Einberufungsbefehl erhalten auch
über diese neue Möglichkeit informiert
und auch über die Nutzungsmöglichkeit
der ID Austria hingewiesen es ist für
mich ein ganz wichtiger Schritt auf
meinem Weg bis ins Jahr 2024 alle
Amtswege zur digitalisieren und das ist
kein selbst Zweck sondern einerseits
Handy angesprochen geht es darum auch
Einsparungen in der Verwaltung dass sich
die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter von
uns auf das konzentrieren können was
akut ansteht wir haben ein eklatanten
Fachkräftemangel auch im öffentlichen
Dienst und andererseits geht es auch
darum die Menschen dort abzuholen wo sie
heute sind die Menschen operieren mit
den neuesten insbesondere junge
Stellungspflichtige mit den neuesten
Smartphone Apps und deshalb muss auch
das Bundesheer online und der
Applikationen des Bundesheers zukünftig
so einfach sein wie tinder etwas mit dem
wir jetzt vielleicht weniger zu tun
haben aber vielleicht der ein oder
andere Stellungspflichtige in diesem
Sinn von Bundesministerin vielen
herzlichen Dank für die gute Kooperation
für die gute Zusammenarbeit und ich
freue mich jetzt auf die Präsentation
bevor wir zu den Fragen der
Medienvertreter kommen würde ich ja
suchen dass die Verteidigungsministerin
und der Herr Staatssekretär bitte Platz
nehmen und ich ersuche den Herrn Herbert
Binder zu mir den Leiter der
Entwicklungsabteilung der uns jetzt
Bilder sprechen lässt und gemeinsam mit
uns den digitalen Fortschritt vorzeigt
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister sehr
geehrter Herr Staatssekretär sehr
geehrter Herr general hoch geschätztes
Auditorium mein Name ist Herbert Binder
ich bin der Leiter des Entwicklerteams
in der Direktion 6 vor mir hinter ihnen
Josef Weissinger am Gerät der das
nachher bedienen wird sowie unser
cyberge in der Abteilung Gefreiter
Moritz Tröstl es freut mich Interesse an
unsere neuen Services ich habe nun die
Ehre sie durch die Live Vorführung zu
führen sie sehen nun den Aufruf des
neuen Services das ist das künftige
citizenportal des österreichischen
Bundesheeres der Zugang der Bürger zu
jenen Services die wir im Rahmen des ich
aber wenn es anbieten werden wir
verwenden hier erprobte Technologie im
igamentbereich wir haben schon gehört
für Identifikation Authentifizierung
Handy Signatur die Austria mein Kollege
wird sich nun mit der Handy-Signatur
identifizieren
da habe ich es ein bisschen Gelegenheit
auch eine kleine Schnute anzubringen
diese Service ist seit gestern online
quasi im scharfen Schuss verfügbar und
wir waren ganz verwundert es sind schon
die ersten eingestiegen und haben es
auch genutzt
erfolgreich genutzt
ich möchte nicht unerwähnt lassen dass
diese Service natürlich künftig auf der
Bundeswehr Homepage verlinkt sein wird
und entsprechend dort erreichbar sein
wird und natürlich auch auf Österreich
gefordert die
ja natürlich
beim Ersteinstieg erscheint ein disklima
und man muss natürlich wenn man diese
Service nutzen möchte diesen Disclaimer
bestätigen das ist aus
Datenschutzrechtlichen rechtlichen
Erfordernissen hin notwendig der
Antragsteller hat hier das ganze zu
akzeptieren und ich versuche nun meinen
Kollegen dass sie drauf drückt und dann
sehen sofort persönliche Daten die hier
nun erscheinen die sind jetzt nun
persönliche Daten die wir nutzen
aufgrund der Wehrpflicht die hier
aufgelesen werden und da möchte ich
nicht unerwähnt lassen ein Großteil
dieser Daten kommen aus dem zentralen
medienregister werden automatisiert über
das zentrale melde Register abgeglichen
das österreichische Bundesheer hat eine
Schnittstelle zum zentralen weltregister
seit über 20 Jahren sondern waren die
ersten die quasi dann Register schon
genutzt haben in der Bundesverwaltung
jene die ist noch vielleicht wissen
früher wo das eigene Durchschlag konnte
man schlecht lesen musste manuell
erfasst werden seit 20 Jahren Geschichte
wir sind also quasi im Register drinnen
nicht nur Registerdaten auch Daten
Kontaktdaten die hier eingegeben werden
können unbedingt der vorteilig ist eine
gültige E-Mail-Adresse die wir benötigen
zum Austausch zwischen Antragsteller und
Behörde für Benachrichtigungen
Zustellungen etc wenn man runter
blättert sehen wir auch die Bankdaten
hier sei nur erwähnt wenn bereits Daten
vorhanden sind auf vorhergehenden
Verfahren dann werden diese ja auch
angezeigt unter Antragsteller kann sie
sofort aktualisieren wenn sie noch nicht
vorhanden sind kann der Antragsteller
seine Bankdaten bekannt geben die sind
immer erforderlich auch wenn man zur
Stellung geht für ein
Fahrtkostenzuschuss für die Abrechnung
der fahrtkostenzuschusses
ein bisschen zu schnell ich wollte dann
noch erwähnen wenn man die Bankdaten
eingibt dann ist es so dass sie
Medienbruch frei weiterverarbeitet
werden das heißt ohne dass ein Referent
noch irgendetwas machen muss wird das
automatisch weiterverarbeitet ich
ersuche nun
dass die möglichen Behördenverfahren die
nun mit diesem Service online verfügbar
sind einmal aufgeklappt werden es wurde
schon angesprochen
Familienunterhalt partnerunterhalt
wohnkostenbeihilfe partnerunterhalt und
wohnkostenbeihilfe Krankenversicherung
von Angehörigen und Bankdaten wir haben
da ansprechende ansprechende Piktogramme
verwendet damit das entsprechend der
Antragsteller schon weiß ja er hat da
geht's um Krankenversicherung da geht's
um wohnkostenbeihilfe und nun vor schwer
zufällig hergestellt hat was ich damit
genommen habe das ist oder nicht meine
lange Rede die ich heute hier abhalte
sondern das ist das komplexe Verfahren
von dem wir hier gesprochen haben bis zu
13 Formulare mit dem Beilagen an die 50
Seiten
das ist schon enorm das ist schon enorm
arbeite hier eingespart werden es wurde
schon angesprochen vom Staatssekretär
und von der Frau Ministerin dass der
doch relativ viel ist ich ersuche nun
mein Kollegen Krankenversicherung von
Angehörigen ja da ist natürlich jetzt
viel mehr erklärtext man muss ja immer
wieder davon ausgehen das sind sehr
komplexe Verfahren auf Anhieb hat es mit
Papier geschafft dass er richtig
aufgeführt hat hier kommen sehr viele
erklärte Texte und man hat auch die
Möglichkeit und hier wird schon verlinkt
auf Österreich gefordert dass wenn man
sich nicht sicher ist wenn man nicht
weiß was das für Begriffe sind dass Du
entsprechende rechtliche Erklärungen
auch angezeigt werden wir werden jetzt
relativ rasch hier durchmischen und
diesen Antrag ausfüllen wir sprechen ja
nicht nur von einer Digitalisierung
besprechen hier wirklich von einer
echten Transformation das heißt also die
entsprechenden Eingabefelder werden
dynamisch aufgebaut und es wird nur das
angeboten was jetzt wirklich Sinn macht
nicht wie beim Papierformular dass man
da natürlich alle möglichen
Eingabefelder hat und groß das wird mit
wird mit lichtboxen also mit
auswahlwerten gearbeitet das heißt es
geht darum dass man den Anwender hier
durchführt und Fehler Eingaben soweit
wie möglich vermeidet natürlich sind
auch normale Prüfung wie ob das eine
gültige Sozialversicherungsnummer ist
und und Untergang da drinnen und ich
würde es da suchen dass man kurz auch
einen Angehörigen erfasst hier also der
erforderlichen Grunddaten dafür eingibt
damit man sich das immer da weiter kommt
auch hier immer wieder auswahlwerte um
so weit wie möglich Fehleingaben zu
vermeiden
ja was man auch noch machen kann und das
ist vielleicht auch ganz wichtig relativ
einfach können Beilagen also Dokumente
wäre Geburtsurkunde wie eine
Heiratsurkunde wenn Einkommensnachweis
hochgeladen werden das erfolgt natürlich
hier eine formalprüfung auf die
Speichergröße hin aus Format und hinten
nach natürlich eine eine Prüfung von
unserer sag einmal selber schuld damit
hier nicht unsere Services komponiert
werden das ist auch ganz wichtig ich
möchte nur erwähnen hier wird ein
Zwiebel ein Zwiebelschalen Architektur
angewandt damit kein direkter Zugriff
möglich ist von Internet in unsere
internen Applikationslandschaft
der Antragsteller hat die Möglichkeit
einen Entwurf abzusprechen ja warum wird
das ist so komplex dass man vielleicht
nicht alle Daten gleich verfügbar hat
dann kann also das einmal aufheben sagen
okay ich muss nur die Geburtsurkunde
irgendetwas raussuchen kann diesen
Entwurf abspeichern und entsprechend
nachher weiter bearbeiten er kann auch
den Antrag übermitteln wir haben hier
eine Sicherheitsabfrage noch eingebaut
damit nicht irrtümlich der Antrag sofort
an die Behörde übermittelt wird so dass
das eine bewusste Tat des Antragstellers
ist
ja mein Kollege übermittelt nun diese
diesen Antrag und jetzt und das ist auch
ganz wichtig der Antragsteller die
Antragstellerin wird immer transparent
jetzt informiert in welchem Status sich
dieser Antrag befindet das ist darum
wichtig man kann sich das leicht
vorstellen früher haben er hatte den
Antrag bekommen wann kann ich erwarten
den Bescheid wann werde ich die
finanziellen Leistungen bekommen der
andere Stelle kann immer transparent
nachvollziehen in welchem Status
befindet sich der Antrag unter
Antragsteller hat doch die Möglichkeit
die Daten die er eingegeben hat an die
Behörde übermittelt hat einzusehen
und und das wurde auch schon kurz
angesprochen es gibt eine Chat
Funktionalität der Antragsteller kann
immer noch Nachrichten auch Dokumente
nachbringen an die Behörde ich würde nur
noch suchen dass man auf die Referenten
Oberfläche kurz rüber switchen damit man
entsprechend sieht wie die Referenten im
jahrespersonalamt künftig arbeitet hier
gibt es unterschiedlichste
Filtermöglichkeiten damit der referente
richtigen korrekten Referenten das wird
noch Buchstaben noch noch Verfahren
entsprechend gefiltert diese Anträge
abarbeitet der Referent kann bei
komplexen Anträgen hier möchte ich nur
erwähnen bei einfachen Anträgen wie zum
Beispiel Bekanntgabe der Bankdaten
braucht man das natürlich nicht da geht
es direkt ins System hinein aber besser
komplexen Anträgen kann eben der
Referent
kontrollieren ob alle erforderlichen
Daten Beilagen vorhanden sind und dann
mit weiterleiten okay
das ist eine kurze Ansicht ein PDF
Dokument wo man noch mal kontrollieren
kann ob alle Daten entsprechend erfasst
wurden mit weiterleiten an Gott das ist
die Geschäftsfall orientierte
Bearbeitung in den zentralen
personalapplikationen des BMV können
diese Daten automatisiert übernommen
werden keine erfassen keine eins können
gar nichts
der Referent hat die Möglichkeit direkt
mit dem Antragsteller Kontakt
aufzunehmen mit dieser schon kurz
angesprochenen Chat Funktionalität das
kann man entweder hier chatten oder auch
Dokumente hochladen und entsprechend
den Antragsteller entsprechend
informieren es fehlt noch diese Urkunde
oder da ist irgendeinen Datenfeld nicht
aufgefüllt worden je nachdem wie wird
der Antragsteller jetzt informiert in
einer modernen Art und Weise er bekommt
auf die bekannt gegebenen E-Mail-Adresse
ein E-Mail wo drinnen steht das neue
Nachrichten verfügbar sind übrigens
nicht nur weil der Referent was bekannt
gibt sondern sich auch der Status
verändert wenn es doch quasi das
Verfahren abgeschlossen ist wenn es
einem Bescheid gibt wie auch immer wird
natürlich bei einer Statusänderung der
Antragsteller entsprechend informiert er
kann dann einstellen einsteigen und
sieht das ist das Symbol das rote Brief
Symbol das genau zu diesem Antrag er
könnte ja in Zukunft mehrere Anträge da
schon laufen haben das genau zu diesem
Antrag eine Nachricht eingegangen ist er
kann sich diese Nachricht anschauen und
entsprechend auch rasch drauf reagieren
es wurde schon erwähnt die jungen Leute
haben das öfteren nur noch ein
Smartphone und kein kein
Notebook der schon zu den älteren ich
habe eine Notebook zu Hause
die jungen Leute haben die Möglichkeit
dass am Ende aufzurufen es wurde im
Responsive Design entwickelt es ist auf
dem Tablet verfügbar es ist auf dem
Handy verfügbar er kann entsprechend
sofort darauf reagieren auf das Ganze
wenn er sich identifiziert
authentifiziert hat über Handy Signatur
die Austria das Dokumente sind noch
fehlt abfotografieren hochladen erledigt
okay ich bekomme schon die rote Karte
doch zu lange gebraucht
ja was gibt es noch zu sagen es wurde
schon erwähnt das ganze insgesamt eine
wien-situation der Antragsteller kommt
früher zu seinen Ansprüchen zu seinen
Leistungen auch zu seinem finanziellen
Leistungen die Behörde erspart sich
erfassungstätigkeiten das kennt
Tätigkeiten wir stehen hier ganz am
Anfang das sind die ersten Verfahren
aber mehr werden an die 100 Verfahren
das ist ungefähr das was in der ersten
Analyse rausgekommen ist
das gibt's doch zu digitalisieren und
das werden wir in den nächsten in der
nächsten Zeit auch machen ich danke für
die Aufmerksamkeit
danke sehr
dann würden wir Fragen direkt zur
Homepage stellen können an den Herrn
Binder
ich glaube keine Fragen unterstreichen
auch die leichte Bearbeitung und
Bedienbarkeit und ich würde sagen damit
beschließe ich die Pressekonferenz und
wir haben jetzt noch die Möglichkeit von
Einzelinterviews danke